while scouring this beach in Lime Kiln
it doesn't take very long to find
nerdles
they're tiny pellets of plastic used by
manufacturers
but spills during handling and
transportation mean instead of ending up
in our Plastic Products too often
they're washing up on shore
where responsibility lies isn't clear
and that's because there's no regulation
on how nerd or spills are managed
despite their environmental impact as
well as just looking not very nice on a
beach and smothering beaches in plastic
unfortunately a lot of noodles are
mistaken for food by a lot of marine
animals animals such as seabirds fish
dolphins and baby turtles as well as
this noodles can carry toxic pollutants
on their surface transporting nasty
chemicals around the world as well
the problem continues to grow this
year's great Global nerd or hunt held by
the environmental charity fedra found
more of the plastic pellets on beaches
around the world than ever before
hunts took place at 317 sites in 23
countries and nirdles were found in 90
of these locations the only country
where no plastic pellets were found was
Indonesia but could we see these numbers
improve in the future
environmentalists are hopeful if
legislation is brought in we need to see
noodles classified formally as Marine
pollutants so that their packaged most
stringently they're labeled more clearly
and the presence of pellets on ships is
communicated to The Operators so they
can be stowed below deck and in more
safe and appropriate manner
they may be small but there's no doubt
that these nerdles pose huge problems
once they're in the environment they're
incredibly difficult to clean up so
Focus needs to be on preventing them
from getting there in the first place
Aisha zahid Sky News